lucasfilm you're killing me over here so
[Music]
I did my response and thoughts on the
solo trailer that came out with the
Superbowl and I said in that that I
didn't expect that I would have to talk
about a fuller length one because I
expected if one was put out that it was
basically just gonna have more of what I
already talked about and not be
substantively different enough that it
would change any my feelings about what
I saw which to reiterate were largely
positive and then the trailer comes out
and there is a whole bunch more that
actually doesn't pike my pain and mainly
we get a fair bit more of the main thing
we didn't get in that previous trailer
which is a better look at seeing and
hearing young Han Solo himself and that
has changed my opinion so part of me is
like well does this render my first one
completely moot and I'm actually gonna
leave that one up because I feel like
now I have a complete picture of what a
smart marketing move that first one was
because and I even said this in that
video that trailer was really all about
selling the vibe some of the visuals the
feel of it and that was a feel that
honestly as somebody who not only didn't
like the last Jedi but who has always
been skeptical of this entire concept of
a young Han Solo movie I dug that vibe I
dug those visuals so the movie actually
pretty much got me on to its side and
without having to sell me on the much
harder thing which is this guy is now
han Solo and now this trailer comes out
and does show me more of Han Solo and
I'm reminded why I thought this was a
bad idea
now that sounds like I'm gonna say this
guy sucks he's a terrible Han Solo and
I'm not prepared to go there I'm sure a
lot of people are pointing out he
doesn't really look like Harrison Ford
he doesn't sound like Harrison Ford but
honestly I could care less River Phoenix
didn't look or sound like he could
possibly conceivably grow up to be
Harrison Ford but he still worked in the
Last Crusade with Indiana Jones so you
know I I don't need him
tolkien sound I
that's superficial it'd be nice I
wouldn't mind it but I don't care
ultimately what I need is I need him to
feel like the same character
I need the character to have the same
voice and when I say voice I don't mean
like sound like him I mean the character
has to exude the same presence that's
what I mean as a character narrative Lee
when interacting with other characters
he has to be saying things in a way
again not about matching voice but
saying things in a way that I believe
Han Solo would say them and sort of
that's where we're not in a great place
again though I don't really want to
blame the actor because I don't think a
ton of this is his fault now this is not
me saying I'm sure he's good he might
not be he might suck but my problems
without with what I'm seeing here aren't
really down to his performance it brings
me back to why I thought this was a bad
idea in the first place and maybe this
just has to do with what I like about
Han Solo in the first place which is I
like him being the cocky fast-talking
you know just playing very loose by the
rules smuggler I like him as that I
don't really want to watch a movie where
eventually he'll become that I wouldn't
have minded a movie set before a new
hope what I'm skeptical about is the
idea that we're seeing it before he was
what we saw and loved so you know it you
know it's like you know what it is it's
like that that weird Russell Crowe Robin
Hood movie where the whole thing is like
about the Crusades and the things that
drove him to become Robin Hood and he
never actually does any significant
Robin hooding
you know the entire thing of Robin Hood
robbed them rich give to the poor
swashbuckling what hey kind of adventure
we don't get any of that because it's an
entire movie of explaining why he would
later do that but that is what everybody
likes about it so just can we just have
that and I may be its origin fatigue
like I don't
saying never care about where characters
come from but honestly I don't need to
know I liked him as he showed up fully
formed in a new hope
seeing him basically not there yet not
finished cooking in this more raw
freeform thing I'm not gonna say can't
work but like you've immediately lost my
interest because this is not the Han
Solo I care about and it's not so much
like I don't believe he could be like
this fine I could probably buy it I'm
sure they'll narratively
justify everything but it's just this is
not what I like about Han Solo you you
are dangling Han Solo in front of me but
the version you're dangling in front of
me isn't Han Solo as I love him so I
don't know it's one of those in that I'm
sure there's gonna be misinterpreted by
some people but like I never walk
characters to change and evolved but
that's part of the problem with doing
you see a prequel as opposed to a sequel
you can't go backwards and have a
character change and evolve because then
you have to explain why they didn't have
that growth that you put in there you
have to actually regress them to make
them less fully formed than they were at
the time that we already know them so
you almost have to actively make a
character less complicated less layered
less finished less complete in order to
do a prequel again not always that there
are some decent prequels out there if I
sat down with a team of archaeologists
and had a month to dig through all the
prequels that I've ever been made I'm
sure I could find a few but I think it's
one of the inherent problems with
prequels particularly when you're not
just setting things prior to events but
you're dealing with characters before
the period in which we first met them so
the the the whole premise and seeing him
in this and hearing him talk and hearing
him be like I want to be a pilot you
know I've been on the street since I was
10 and I've been pulling scams and I'm
gonna be the best there is and I'm just
thinking you're a jerk you're a jerk who
hasn't seen enough crap that like I'm
okay with it because that's almost kind
of Han Solo's shtick he was kind of a
jerk when we first met him but he was a
jerk who'd seen some stuff so it felt it
felt legit it's like yeah you've been
through stuff
I get why you shoot first and when you
go younger than that I
it comes across more like it just kind
of a cocky little aren't you so yeah now
that said all the stuff that I liked in
the original teaser I still like the
visuals look great I love the sort of
heist II cantina II vibe that I get from
the whole thing I enjoy all that but and
again I've got to come back - that was a
real smart marketing move that they did
that because that trailer did what I
said it would do which was that trailer
now made me kind of want to like this
movie because I liked that trailer and
I've got a new trailer which I don't
like so much but I find myself looking
for the reasons to still like it cuz
they maybe not completely but kind of
mostly sold it to me when they had the
trailer that had as little of Han Solo
as possible so I think that regardless
of whether or not he's actually good in
the part regardless that or not of
whether he just sucks as an actor er I
think they know that people are going to
have a more visceral visceral sort of
not my hashtag not my solo reaction to
him so I think it was just very
calculated and in a smart way to just
put out a trailer to show them as little
as possible that feels fun and then show
them after that and hopefully you don't
lose as many people because you get
people like me who go
you have what that first trailer really
did look fun and pretty so if this had
been the Superbowl trailer that came out
I certainly wouldn't have been this
positive on it as I was with the teaser
trailer but in the end yeah I mean I'm
probably still gonna go watch this thing
I will say just myself my minor
annoyance cuz I'm sure it's just an
action set piece it's not particularly
you know story relevant I don't like
that they showed us the
spikey tentacley you know Cthulhu shook
[ __ ] wrath looking thing in the the
swirling vortex I don't like they showed
us that and that's not me saying that I
don't like that it's there but what was
intriguing to me about that whole
swirling thing was that I had no clue
what it wasn't like this is new and now
I know it it's hiding monsters there's
monsters in it and I mean that's not
uncool but you perfectly sold me on the
oh I want to find out what that is and
now I feel like I kind of already know
what it is and now I don't care so nice
work on that so that's me after of Harry
I guess about hmm 1214 hours or so of
being like you know what maybe this
could work I get popped back down to
earth but not quite with a hard enough
landing that it'll stop me from seeing
this movie because I did see enough that
I liked in that first one and saw more
of it and this one that I'll probably
still go see this and you know I love
Star Wars and I want it to be good and I
want this movie to be good I don't think
it will be I would like it to be so that
is where I am and my thoughts on the
full trailer for so low a Star Wars
story I'm really sorry that this is now
two days in a row that I put out two
videos in the same day I don't like
doing that I feel like I'm spamming
people subscription feeds when I do that
but you know I I don't want to sit on
these trailer responses because then if
I do by the time I get something out
everyone's like yeah we've moved on the
conversation is done with this so those
are my thoughts on the full version of
the trailer first solo Star Wars story
what are your thoughts whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all those
things for you to do check out patreon
Twitter my podcast links for all this
stuff is down below and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]